this talk is titled how not to become a
senior developer not to be confused with
how to not become a senior developer
which is it don't just don't do it this
suggests that there are several
approaches and that some might be better
than than the others so when I was when
I was writing this presentation it came
out as a sort of stream-of-consciousness
thing and it didn't want to conform any
other format because the ideas inside
orbit interconnected so I just try to
make it as coherent as possible and what
I want to do is reveal a little bit
about how I reason about my work as VP
engineering and the work of our
programmers and our field in general and
some of these ideas might not apply to
you directly and that is fine the point
is not in the details of the ideas
really it's in the reasoning about the
ideas and I'm hoping to help you get a
bigger picture of whatever context
you're working in right now and your
journey to becoming a senior developer
so the talk might be slightly mislabeled
because I will only talk very briefly
about how I think you should not become
a senior developers so one of the most
popular and according to me probably the
most incorrect way is just list out a
number of technologies that you should
learn and then once you reach the bottom
of the list you are a senior developer
so I understand that the idea is
extremely compelling because it becomes
a journey that is bite-sized and
gamified and it's just about memorizing
new tools and because we are developers
we tend to have high learning capacity
and a keen interest in what we're doing
so the prospect of just learning some
new frameworks or tools is very
compelling
and I'm not saying you shouldn't learn
any technologies of course you need to
know something to be able to do work but
I think about it as a prerequisite so I
like to say that it's required to know
these things but it's not sufficient to
do a good job and I don't place too much
confidence in better tools history has
shown that better tools tend to allow us
to be bigger and more complex software
just as poorly as we were able to build
smaller and most more simple software
previously and the only thing that that
creates better software is improving the
people so as a disclaimer this is some
report that has our developer roadmap
and I don't know the person who created
it and it's a great thing because it
works as a reference for sort of what
the ecosystem looks like right now in
terms of technologies so you can use
this to get an overview but I wouldn't
treat it as a roadmap to becoming a
senior developer it's probably a roadmap
to something else if you follow it
blindly and there is a trap and that
trap is called expert beginner ship so
if you are if you've been in teaching or
education this is the bottom part is
Dreyfus model of skill acquisition and
when we reach the advanced beginner
stage and this is a stage of just
accumulating facts and putting them
inside us we sort of see our fork in the
road and one of the paths later on to be
more competent and beyond to become an
actual expert and that path involves
getting the big picture of what we're
doing but there is also another path
which is the trap into expert beginner
ship and that is
treating it as ourselves as sort of a
bucket that just needs to be filled with
more and more low level implementation
details and I I think that this simple
accumulation effects is not really
enough it has been talked about in the
terms of just more and more content but
just letting the ideas pass to us
without interacting with any of like our
reactive parts isn't that hard and we
need to let the ideas sort of transform
our understanding of what it is we're
doing so I show hands who knows about
continuous integration ok who does
continuous integration at work ok so
continuous integration is is the act of
bringing the team's systems together and
making sure they work together but what
is it we're actually integrating out
it's not really code because that's just
making the characters work together we
could argue that we're integrating our
systems but when we do continuous
integration I like to think of it also
as an integration of ideas and I
I extend this concept to myself as well
I constantly to integrate the ideas of
others with my current latticework of
ideas and I like to think of this as
laying a latticework or weaving sort of
a web of ideas and I think as a junior
developer you have an advantage here
because you can look at your seniors and
you can look at this web and you can see
these are the really nice part I'm just
gonna take that and integrate it into my
own but you can also see the thorny
parts where the ends don't really meet
in my understanding and in my
integration of ideas so you can use that
as a counter example and say oh that is
really contradicting himself on these
things so I'm going to avoid ending up
there whereas for me who has been doing
this integration over this for a very
long time changing that part might take
a lot of work so just be critical and by
critical I don't mean being
closed-minded I come across junior
developers who tend to reject everything
until they have sort of experienced it
themselves or inferred the things from
first principles but I think this is a
bit of a waste of the potential of
having mentors and having seniors around
you who have experienced things and who
can warn you about certain certain
missteps and then of course pick up the
ideas that that are the best ideas you
heard of so far knowing that he will
come across something better and then be
ready to drop
so this actually everything I will say
about what's not to do so the rest of
the talk about the dedicates to talking
about things we can do instead how we
can reason about our work and I think
reasoning about our work is how we can
get better at it and this will hopefully
eventually allow juniors who are at the
advanced beginner stage to graduate the
competent stage and I'd like to start
this part by asking a question the
question is how long is a string and if
you have if you think that this question
is nonsensical that is on purpose this
particular question is a rhetorical
device that's used in my home country
which is Sweden and we use it as a
retort when someone asks us a question
that doesn't have enough information for
enough context to be answered in any
meaningful way and it's often paired
with another saying which is the way you
ask the question is the way I will
answer it and although we all can seem
to agree that this question without any
supplementary information is quite
absurd we see people ask questions like
this seriously and people trying to
answer them seriously but we this
question is equally absurd we could
approach it with sort of an empirical
mindset and say that well if there was a
best programming language everyone will
be using it and there will only be one
right which is not true or we can
approach it with a rational mind set and
see that programming languages seem to
necessitate certain trade-offs and how
we value those trade-offs determines how
good it is or not that is to say it is a
subjective evaluation and the third and
absolute the worst option is that we can
approach it with sovereign emotional
mindsets where we value our own attached
or affiliations with certain programming
programming languages and to me it seems
like the first option is is the best one
having the empirical mindset we can look
at outcomes which is a very powerful
model model to have to reason about the
outcomes that we're looking for and a
lot of times we don't really have enough
data to make an empirical judgment and
we need to resort to the the rationale
the rationale mode of reasoning about
things but reasoning about things is
very thorny place to be because human
reasoning is is fundamentally very
flawed and especially when the emotional
part comes in as well so be very careful
careful that rationalism can very easily
turn into sort of religious dogma as
well but if we were given the choice I
prefer to never have feelings about code
or feelings about ideas because it it
seems to be a dead end to me it sort of
locks my locks me in so whenever I find
myself typing in a code review I feel I
just tend to stop myself and say why am
I feeling anything about this very
objective piece of the system because it
probably means I have some unexplored
things there so be candid and question
things objectively whenever you can and
I'm going on with the questions here is
JavaScript a bad language who has ever
proclaimed that javascript is a terrible
language or made jokes about it or used
it as an icebreaker okay
so most likely the reason for that was
emotional we had some bad experience in
there firsthand where we had heard a
story from someone else about how bad
their experience was but if we tried the
other mindsets empirically javascript is
a great language because tons and tons
of people are using it successfully for
tons and tons of things if you try the
rational mindset we can sort of start to
articulate what what what our gripes
with JavaScript are so we can look at
what is used for we use it for UI so
it's evented that's cool we have events
in UI but it's general-purpose and UI is
sort of specific applications we could
probably do with something more
specialized it's imperative which is not
so nice because you eyes tend to lend
themselves to a declarative approach so
then we can we can revise our judgment
that it's a bad language into it's
probably a bad philosophical fit for you
is for the web but it could be a great
language if you are building a heavily
invented and streaming system for
example and this sort of unlocks the
trap of that emotion where we look at a
word or a name and we have a negative
emotion and then we just try to avoid it
and I think abandoning these emotional
evaluations and resorting to reasoning
or empiricism is can yield some very
important insights so if you look at
this question and we start exploring it
it leads to a very important insight
that programming is not really one
single homogeneous discipline and
just because the different disciplines
share the common denominator that we
write code doesn't mean that they have
the same challenges and constraints and
I think we should consider them
different disciplines as a whole and if
you're a games programmer maybe you need
to know linear algebra by heart if
you're a web developer maybe you don't
need to know any linear algebra but you
need to understand the the business
domain and you need to be intimately
familiar with user behavior if you are
building embedded applications maybe you
need to be on top of memory management
and CPU cycles which is wasted effort in
other applications and I like to even
say that programming is not about code
that much and that might be heresy like
what who is this guy saying that program
is not about code there is this t-shirt
that says that programmers are people
who turn coffee into code and all true
wisdom is found on t-shirts right what I
think programming is about code in the
same sense that writing is about words
it's just a means that we use to express
our ideas and what is important or those
ideas themselves and I think program is
about systems in the same sense that
writing is about stories so just when we
are while we're at it this this is not
really a junior developer question this
is like I want to be a developer
question so which language should you
learn first any takers
it could be yes okay just send me your
resume after okay
you should learn English because really
we're we're we're translating problems
and ideas from natural language into
code and if we cannot articulate those
problems or ideas in natural language
then we have a really bad starting point
it doesn't matter how good we are at
writing code so after you learn your
first language English and your first
program language
what should you learn next maybe maybe
if if you are into like 3d programming
then that might be a good good idea but
as Wei Lian pointed out it's the might
be the wrong question we need to ask but
I want to do what problems are MI
solving what kind of programming do I
want to get into and don't accept
run-of-the-mill universal answers to
questions like this because there there
tend to be not okay so explore a bit
further we do a show of hands again who
here would say they work in a technology
company
okay and who would say they work in a
product company okay I have no idea
what's the rest of you are doing I know
there are no more options what I like to
differentiate between the two and
biotechnology company I tend to mean a
company where new technology is invented
and where the primary constraint is the
technology and by-product company I tend
to mean companies where we take existing
technology and we assemble it into
product that solves particular problems
for some field yes so some large
companies do both so Google is the most
Google is the most prominent example
right they create the technology but
they also build products from it because
they are large enough to be able to do
everything but because the constraints
and the challenges are different what's
required from you as a senior developer
is is different so there's no one path
to to senior developer shift and
anecdotally I think this means
misconception the programming is a
single discipline you can lead to a sort
of lack of work satisfaction so I met a
lot of programmers who are quite unhappy
and they are jumping from product
company to provide company and they do
they are very into deep technology and
they don't realize that these companies
that they are joining are not like gated
playgrounds where you can work with deep
tech they are doing something else they
are solving other other products and
these product companies tend to be
rather open business almost arenas that
have human contexts that might not be
interesting to those really interested
in tech so I'm going to go on and talk
about product companies so if you work
in a technology company feel free to to
follow along
I like to think that all product
development is integrated and that is
because products have many interfaces so
a product interfaces at least with
different markets and with different
users and with technology which is why
we have different teams for dealing with
those different interfaces so we can
have a product owner who interfaces with
the market we can have engineering team
that interfaces with technology and
design team that interfaces with users
and these tend to answer different
questions so the product owner
at the designer can answer what true it
looks like and the developer says how
what is the best approach to building
this and that work is sort of done in in
isolation but I don't think that the
real magic happens in the intersections
or what I call the arena's so for
example if you have product and
development come together product knows
how valuable something is and
development knows how hard something is
to build and then summary we know what
is the return on investment for building
a certain thing which informs when we
should build it in what order but this
requires us to understand the objectives
and under and constraints of the other
functions as well because if we don't
understand their objectives then we
cannot make the right compromise this or
we cannot negotiate when it's
appropriate but of course we should
obsess about our own objectives the most
because those are the ones we need to to
defend so what then is the objective of
the development team we could be misled
to think that it is value because value
is our deliverable what products are
already obsessing about value so that
seems wrong if our objectives are the
same there wouldn't be any need for
negotiation in the first days and I tend
to think the objective of the
development team is flow that is we
develop we deliver value today and we do
it continuously and indefinitely and I
think we should obsess about that and
the biggest threat to flow and the
greatest enemy of the development team
is complexity and I think all complexity
added to our code base should needs to
be thoroughly examined and tested for
necessity before we commit to it
this means that solutions to four
problems are a big no-no and that
applies even if it means adding our own
favorite technology or pattern to to the
problem because we all have pet
solutions and technologies but as
professionals we need to sort of stuff
them into a drawer and wait until the
right problem calls with because all
solutions also come with their own
problems and there's no such thing as a
free feature or a free framework so I
use this chart with business people to
illustrate the typical trajectories for
flow the red line sort of illustrates
what happens if we cut a lot of corners
early on in order to achieve some
short-term delivery maybe we're not
writing any tests we're not really doing
any modeling we're just focusing on
grinding out features but if we ask the
product owner in one month from now
would you like eight units of value or
one unit they're going to say eight
units and it's important for us to
protect protect our objective of flow
and explain to the product owner that if
we do that we're screwed for it which
brings us to another question I'm doing
these questions just make sure you're
you're awake so assuming we took the red
pill and now we're knee-deep into the
complexity debt and everyone is
miserable it is it better to rebuild the
project or to salvage it so we can do a
show of hands how many think is better
to rebuild okay how many think it's
better to salvage
okay I've tried both several times and I
will tell you the answer so the answer
is the question is it better to rebuild
or to salvage is no I can tell you that
both are extremely miserable experiences
and they are demoralizing and
soul-crushing and it's not something you
want to go through so the answer is for
us to sort all maintain our professional
integrity and defend our objective
before it can happen and this this is
extremely hard and it can't protect us
from legacy code bases that came in like
from from elsewhere but I think it's the
only way to be part of the solution so
in practice this involves deciding on
some what is our maximum tolerable death
level and make sure we don't exceed it
and I think this is mostly done by
making good decisions in in our
day-to-day work and I'm a strong
believer in like the compounding effects
of small improvements and the
compounding effects of small regressions
is equally powerful in the other
direction and there might be short
stints or cleanup but don't buy into the
don't buy into the myth of the Big Bang
refactoring because it never works
because refactoring requires very deep
contextual knowledge of the parts of the
app you're working on so you can't do
like bread refactoring you have to go
depth wise and it requires you to have
all the details loaded into your working
memory which takes time we need to ask
ourselves when we accrue depth why are
we doing it and this is
from martin fowler's
blog so it's it's subdivides death into
reckless or prudent and inadvertent and
deliberate so you can see reckless
deliberates is saying things like we
don't have time for a design which is
this is abandoning our objective in
favor of some other other objective
there might be reckless inadvertent as
june she said you this is where we need
to ask questions to our senior
developers because we don't know what
we're doing read it can be prudent and
and deliberate saying we must chip now
and deal with the consequences and the
key word there there is deal with the
consequences which means we need to
negotiate with the product owner yes we
can deliver next week but then we need
some time to recover from the debt that
winger
there's prudent inadvertent like we
didn't know that it was gonna go so bad
disapproved and as I as I mentioned
product development has an acutely human
context and at some end of the chain
humans will interact with the product
and even if those humans are other
developers they are still humans as well
so if you look outside your own products
team there's a sea of stakeholders that
usually your product owner will protect
you from by being the the authority on
what to build one and these stakeholders
they provide their candidates problems
for us to solve it doesn't mean that we
will solve all them but what they do
have in common is that they are human
problems so they tend to be
unconstrained by any form of logic or
reason because that's the nature of
human problems they tend to be fussy and
this matters a lot because getting the
problem right is the hardest and most
important part of of the job and getting
interim of a means imminent defeat
regardless of how beautiful the the
solution is or how flawless the the
execution because we were not so right
problem in the first place so no I don't
think you need to think like a computer
so there was this trendy like
computational thinking and algorithmic
thinking I think mostly you need to
think like a human it's undefined
properly so we can solve them
and it's to take take ideas from the
natural language that you use and
thirdly turn those ideas into code
mostly we need strong conceptual
thinkers so so focus on that stuff and
because we are solving human problems
which are fussy and not well isolated
and defined like the problems we receive
in school there's no magic formula
really to follow and it doesn't really
help to learn algorithmic thinking and
in a way this is very nice because if if
programming was deterministic it would
be a paradox in itself because
programmers tend to automate things
so if proclaiming was deterministic we
will be able to automate it and we would
have automated Ettore and we would be
out of jobs so I'd like to show you this
mental model which I used to make sure
that we're solving the right problems
which is the most important part so I
consider three parts of any effort I
consider the diagnosis the definition
and the framing of the problem the
prescription how it intend to solve that
problem and the execution which is just
typing on the equipment and I put them
in order of importance this is like
orders of magnitude from the left to the
right and I think it again it shows the
relative insignificance of code it's
just committing the ideas that we
already generated in the previous steps
into into code and it's those ideas that
matter but you should be fluent with
your programming language which is not
really not that hard compared to all the
other things we do so it just means read
up on the standard library and
language syntax so that he uses it
fluently to express ideas just like you
would English but don't be tricked into
thinking that is what makes you a good
developer so just like learning the
entire English dictionary doesn't make
your Hemingway learning Ruby's standard
library it does not make you brilliant
at EDD coding an execution is still
important and this has to do with partly
with credibility so can talk a bit about
spelling errors in the newspaper and it
doesn't kind of doesn't matter how
relevant the story is if it's all with
spelling errors the credibility is
already already heard so don't abandon
it try to improve your execution with
every with every task and this is
usually people can get
sometimes I'll say oh it's just an
implementation Ethan and what I mean by
that is we have already gone through the
process of diagnosis and prescription
which are the interest reports how we
type out the code is not that
interesting to me okay in the interest
of time my own guidelines as we I just
discussed I think better humans meet
better tools every time and I think
technical competence is required but
it's not sufficient and I think what
lies beyond technical competency is what
sets you apart
that's the developer always think about
constraints if you do web applications
and you're thinking should I do this
language level optimization to my Ruby
code the answer is no because the
constraints of performance is IO
and the constraint of your team is
developer resources you're trading very
valuable developer resources for very
non valuable board work but also think
about constraints in in your
organization and your team if especially
if your team is the bottleneck because
then we need to utilize the our effort
wisely obsess about flow make sure
you're solving real problems this is
probably the most important one and
don't have feelings about code so these
are just my guidelines you should
probably develop your own guidelines as
you go along so whenever you come across
an idea that is especially that
integrates especially well with your
understanding of our work then make it
your own
I think finally we need to beat the
stereotype so programming is not
manufacturing and you are not part of
any manufacturing economy and there is
the stereotype of the code monkey and we
don't want to be code monkeys and being
the big monkey does not mean
knowing the most tricks and I think the
best antithesis to the the code monkey
is is credible discerning and reflecting
professionals and professionals who
holds and protects their own objectives
and who know when to negotiate and went
to compromise and one who can tell
conceptual issues from implementation
issues and we reframe the problem and
propose other solutions and I think it's
it's developers who know what they know
and what what they don't so we need both
developers as involved not not both
and of course for everything else
there's always Dakota
[Applause]